oh
nous sommes des étudiants et étudiantes
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin en master 2 de événementiel
médiation des arts et les sciences et
nous avons pour mission cette année
d'organiser un colloque sur paris saclay
notamment sur le patrimoine de paris
saclay il ya quatre tables rondes la
première table ronde c'est le regard sur
la place des femmes de sciences à paris
saclay donc qui parle de la parité
homme-femme et en plus de la place de la
femme dans la science ensuite il y avait
le savoir son enseignement entre
héritage et innovation pour savoir un
peu qu'elle était l'évolution de
l'enseignement pour des années et
comment paris saclay réussi à fonder un
enseignement un peu commun et ce matin
nous avions les acteurs de paris saclay
comment fédérer la diversité avec une
table ronde sur les réseaux de paris
saclay est enfin là nous avons une table
ronde sur comment valoriser le
patrimoine d'hier pour inventer le
patrimoine de demain sur tout ce qui est
patrimoine architectural et naturel de
paris-saclay tous ceux qui ont raté ce
colloque qui pourront toujours le
retrouver en vie